hello and welcome to this video playing
Sita probably okay let's see if he can
he or she can break this Petra off the
fence
this move is still taking people by
surprise
no 95 is also a fine move let's see him
down I can go - should be 7 or 95 I'm
not really a very knowledgeable here I
have to admit when I looked at this
while ago I was basically very early on
concluding ok this is a position I can
play but you probably need a little bit
more non knowledge to really play it
against higher level opponents okay
Bishop age 7 should not work in this
position yeah this is slightly annoying
this move always you don't want to go b6
that looks a bit loose Tim it goes to f5
did not really think about that
yeah so how do we play this hymn do I
get the night hmm what is White's doing
here he's six maybe no no I'm uncertain
maybe night bring the night to the sea
for square it's not really helping me
all that much
it looks it's a looks good on c4 because
it cannot be attacked but does it really
do more than a from c6 yeah maybe I have
c6 just to protect the pawn which is an
advantage over having it on c6 but God
seemed okay that was there what was the
intention anyway
see six he will go a six it's not really
what you want
but it's tough to not play c6 it's at
one point or another
the 94 is also very annoying if I go b6
mmm
tough to play
hmm and the night would be a lot better
on e6 for example okay that is some
spontaneous decision now just saying
okay if you want is six and and then
okay do it it gives me a couple of
squares f4 I'm giving the exchange
that's what I'm trying to say you know
not very sophisticated way maybe
actually maybe I can go Bishop d6
and just just drops back
just drops back
he succeed so Bishop d6 hmm I can never
move this rock as an annoyance yeah this
was an additional idea of his Bishop g3
move I was I spotted it but I couldn't
really didn't really see anything that I
could do would prevent it yeah it wants
to
wants to maybe go rogue Ji Won
[Music]
you know I've had nicer positions
yeah no it's a total disaster
we should be 5 4 Queen g8 maybe all
right he can promote of course just like
that yeah that was that was really
really tough it looked like very strong
play guys really high rated also in
Rapids and and not so much in bullet
yeah it's tough to say him
what what what happened here again I'm
not an expert on all that
just like developing normally that was
an extremely annoying annoying setup if
it cannot really take I mean I did at
some point you take on f5 but I don't
know if bringing the night to see force
is good I mean it's what the engine also
suggests I made one blunder yeah maybe
near the end or something yeah so c6
yeah this is all looking very strong b5
rookie idea I didn't quite know what you
do really it is such a difficult to play
position
I kind of knew that rookie aid isn't
great but I didn't see any constructive
plan is the thing yeah Quincy eight and
I didn't know what to do really
I mean just like he can't pile up and I
don't have anything night between Oh
night be true
he just blundered a five year for
nothing that's really stupid and now it
gets even stronger just this and I'm
winning this and the game probably okay
yeah I mean I really had an
uncomfortable position yeah I'm still
not totally lost he understand this but
I mean Here I am this is made you know
okay he blundered into this night b2
which I didn't see but other than that
it looked very good I think what he did
look very convincing to me yeah again I
don't really know the opening I know
that this is actually what I looked at
when I studied the whole thing simply
looking to take the to take the bishop
and that's a super important piece and
maybe with hindsight this is better I
just felt like d5 cannot be a bad move
and it probably isn't but the way it
turned out it was very difficult for me
to play and I think spite the blonde
they did a good job down yeah thanks a
lot for watching